It is a very deep
dive with a lot of repercussions to that
come up too fast.
Bubbles would form inside your blood,
inside your tissues
and cause ill effects.
To get to 90 meters
you'd be looking at 4 or 5 minutes
to get down there.
It's very dark because
you're very deep.
So there's very little light penetration
and you come down in the dark
and you start to slowly realize
there's some shape coming up ahead
underneath you.
The atmosphere at the break
when you arrive there is quite spooky.
The very first thing I noticed was
there was a lot of net.
It was basically rope netting,
so very heavy,
but it does cover everything.
The problem was that
we were not 100% sure that the
that the ship is Karlsruhe.
So we decided to go and try and find
the name written on the ship,
which in a more luxurious ship
would be bronze or brass
letters riveted into the hull.
As we near the bough,
the amount of netting seemed
to increase.
And what you don't want to do as a
diver is try to get under it
because that risks you being trapped,
tangled within it.
To be able to uncover the letters,
we had to cut
some of the nets away.
It wasn't easy, but eventually,
once the nets dropped away,
we could finally see what lay beneath.
And what became apparent was that
the the bridge area
was heavily damaged.
There's a huge hole in the middle
of the ship.